- And if you wind back the
history of our own planet
to almost quarter of a billion years ago.
This is the map of how our world looked
240 million years ago.
Back then, if we rewind this video tape
of our planet's history and
the constant scudding around
across the surface.
In this period of history,
they'd all collided together
and fused into a single giant landmass,
a super continent,
called Pangea, the 'All Land.'
And held just in the cup of
that C-shaped supercontinent
was the Tethys Ocean,
which over time, grew and expanded,
as the Atlantic is doing right now.
Until Pangea ripped itself
tore itself apart again,
and Africa and then India rode back north
to re-collide, to back end
and this kind of pile up
on the motorway of Earth's continents,
closing up the Tethys as they went.
Destroying the ancient ocean
swallowing it back down into the interior
of the planet.
This is about 15 million years ago.
This great ocean of Tethys now exists
as no more than a narrow seaway.
It was closed off at both ends,
and now exist as no more
than the puddle of Atlantic.
And it's that fact,
the history of the Tethys in Mediterranean
that explains that grand theme
through our human history.
That because it is Africa
that is riding North and
colliding into Eurasia,
it's crumpled up all
that northern coastline
into the Alps, Carpathians,
the Caucasians.
This is a crumpled, rippled landscape.
And with the rising of the sea levels
since the end of the last Ice Age
it is now become a drowned
submerged landscape.
The northern Mediterranean
is absolutely riddled
with natural inlets and coves
and bays and therefore natural harbors.
It is perfectly set up.
Perfectly conducive
for seafaring societies
for trading and communicating
with each other by ships.
Whereas the southern half Mediterranean,
the African coastline
is flat and straight and boring.
It has no natural harbors.
Apart from Carthage here,
which as you can see is
actually just on the lip
of effectively a subterranean mountain
of sub marine mountain
range linking the toe of Italy.
It's about the only place
you can find a natural
harbor in a 1000 miles
of coastline around here.
And so it's that that
explains this great disparity
for thousands of years of human history.
It is bestowed, it's created
by the history of the Mediterranean
and these planetary forces.